Державний регулятор у Болгарії заднім числом повинен
перерахувати ціни на російський природний газ
за період із серпня 2019-го по лютий цього року.
Таким чином болгарським споживачам повернуть
близько 75 мільйонів євро.
Болгарський прем'єр Бойко Борисов назвав
зниження ціни на російський газ на 40%
"символічним подарунком" до річниці визволення Болгарії
від Османського іга, яка відзначалася напередодні.
Саме цю фразу глави болгарського уряду
процитували багато російських ЗМІ. Але чи справді
в цьому випадку можна говорити про подарунок "Газпрому"?
- У 2018 році "Газпром" під тиском регулятора газового ринку в Європі,
тобто фактично Єврокомісії, погодився привести
ціни на газ у відповідність відразу для кількох держав.
Це три балтійські країни, Польща та Болгарія.
Оскільки з'ясувалося, що ціна, яку сплачують
болгари за російський газ, у більш ніж півтора рази
вища за ціни на газових хабах.
Тобто "Газпром", по суті, виконав свої обіцянки,
дані ним ще у 2018 році, причому не на 50%,
як очікувалося, а на 40,  зазначає експерт.
Чому ж "Газпром" пішов на такі істотні поступки?
- Для цього були технічні та політичні передумови.
Технічні - те, що Болгарія створила і нині продовжує
створювати інфраструктуру, аби отримувати газ
із інших напрямів, окрім "Газпрому" та Росії.
Політичні передумови - це робота Єврокомісії, тобто
Європейського Союзу в останні роки. ЄС зламав
правила, які довгі роки "Газпром" нав'язував
своїм партнерам, особливо у Східній Європі.
За цими правилами "Газпром" постачав газ
у певну країну і та не мала права перепродавати
чи передавати цей газ у сусідні країни. В результаті
кожна країна отримувала - залежно від
монопольного статусу "Газпрому" - свою ціну.
Євросоюз зламав це правило, сказавши,
що в нас єдиний газовий ринок.
Цікаво, що і в Софії особливо відзначили
ту важливу роль, яку в процесі переговорів
із "Газпромом" зіграла Єврокомісія.
Багато коментаторів вказують на те, що "Газпром"
погодився прив'язати ціну на газ для Болгарії
до котирування західноєвропейських газових хабів,
фактично відмовившись від нафтової індексації
в контракті. Але чи може це в майбутньому
зіграти важливу роль для споживачів російського газу в Європі?
- Усього 17% газу, який "Газпром" продає в Європі,
все ще прив’язані до нафтового котирування,
тобто до ціни мазуту - літнього й зимового,
а решта або лише частково прив’язана,
або в основному вони орієнтуються на ціни
на газових хабах. На ті ціни, які визначаються ціною
природного скрапленого газу. Тобто "Газпром" нині
фактично змагається з постачальниками СПГ - скрапленого газу.
Експерти певні: "Газпром" просто змушений
пристосовуватися до нової ситуації на газовому ринку
й не може більше диктувати умови своїм клієнтам
у Європі. Перспективи газового гіганта також
затьмарюють і виділений Вашингтоном
мільярд доларів на розвиток ГТС- інфраструктури
країн ЄС і надзвичайно тепла зима.